welcome back guys and as the Sun comes
up over New Hampshire voting is already
underway in many places in fact most
places in fact this place where I'm
standing
voters are checking in right there and
they are casting their votes behind me
behind those curtains with Lady Liberty
this is the 100th year of New
Hampshire's first in nation primary and
I know Keith is joining me to talk about
how that tradition began and why it may
be under threat yeah good morning Tony
good morning everyone this is so high
stakes because in the last 40 years
nobody has gotten to the White House
without winning either I actually only
one president has gotten to the White
House without winning either Iowa or New
Hampshire and after that app miss
happened Iowa last week there are now
many people wondering whether that state
and this state should take their first
in a nation status for granted New
Hampshire voters don't just make
presidents they like to meet them most
Americans never get to see a president
of the United States in person but in
New Hampshire they're spoiled and
spoiled with all this selfies took hands
jerk bumped fists and babies kissed will
switch to Walter Cronkite all right
let's take a look at our returns it's a
century old tradition New Hampshire
voters use every bit of Yankee ingenuity
to get to the polls one well-known dog
sled race are offered voters a sledding
taxi service but in a recent editorial
the Boston Globe argued it's time to
kill the tradition pointing out Iowa and
New Hampshire more resemble
nineteenth-century America than the more
diverse country today it is more diverse
than people realize we're rooted in
small-town democracy we do town meetings
and New Hampshire has a state law
requiring it to hold the first
presidential primary
good evening them the first violence of
campaign 76 the New Hampshire primary
gained national prominence in the 1970s
I guess you really are the front
well I guess so Ronald Reagan was more
confident as he confronted the moderator
in a 1980 debate his campaign funded you
turn that microphone off please
Democratic senator Gary Hart was on
target with his acts in 84 but missed
the mark three years later when asked to
explain why he spent a night with a
Miami model on a yacht named monkey
business I do not have to answer that
question the question was have you ever
committed adultery and Gary Hart never
really answered it
this answer helped in Bob Dole's 88
campaign stop lying about my record
George Bush won that year's primary by
pulling out the tiny guns that weapon
can kill the pilot of an airplane when
Pat Buchanan crashed the party with an
upset in 96 he warned Washington they're
coming all the peasants are coming with
pitchforks after Gary Bauer's candidacy
was a flop after he fell off the stage
flipping pancakes and after his polls
plummeted Bill Clinton asked New
Hampshire to make him to come back kid
I'll never forget who gave me a second
chance and I'll be there for you to the
last dog guys Clinton didn't win that
primary but he did come back to campaign
for his wife Hillary against Barack
Obama he's very likeable I agree with
that
you're likeable enough on the eve of the
primary Clinton had a rare show of
emotion I just don't want to see us fall
backwards she went on to win New
Hampshire but not the nomination and
eight years later fell short to Bernie
Sanders here thank you
don't Hampshire we'll find out tonight
if Bernie Sanders becomes the first non
president to win back-to-back primaries
here in New Hampshire and Tony a little
bit of trivia for you the only person to
win a New Hampshire primary three times
in modern era Richard Nixon that is a
fun fact because he ran did not get the
nomination did not win and then ran for
president and was reelected that's right
three times yeah
Gailen Anthony I've got a little bit
more trivia for you New Hampshire has
been so decisive in fact knocked an
incumbent president out in 1968 Lyndon
Johnson finished second here in New
Hampshire decided you know what America
one-term is enough for me
well president Trump take a similar path
don't count on it and you name who beat
him
who beat Lyndon Johnson I want to say
McGovern I think it was Eugene McCarthy
but I have to look it up you're right
you're all right Bennett's right jogs my
memory I love God I loved Ed's piece
that was great
that was really great I'd forgotten
about Gary Powers flipping back the
pancakes and falling over back we've
seen that before oh thank you guys